good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is focus over to you Steve Jobs you know
we try to hire really smart people but
we have a very simple organization and
we try to focus and do very few things
well and focusing is hard because
focusing doesn't mean saying yes it
means saying no so we say we decide not
to do a lot of things so we can focus on
a few handfuls of things and do them
well and I think you know everybody
working the company wants to do
something great they want to be excited
about what they're working on and and
they want to be recognized for it when
if they do a really great job so we just
try to allow people to do the best work
of their lives at Apple and get it out
to 25 million customers that we have and
that's very exciting and when you're
working on something and you know this
works out up to 25 million people are
going to use this it's very motivating
hmm and it's not just 25 million of our
customers but other companies tend to
follow us you know it takes them a few
years but other companies tend to copy
what we do if it works and and so we can
influence the whole industry your
chances of success go up in direct
proportion to your ability to one pick
the right things to work on and then to
focus on executing those things it's so
easy as an entrepreneur to get
distracted we love shiny objects right
we love dreaming up new ideas and
chasing these different projects but if
you look at a typical entrepreneur
you'll see that so many of their
projects start and stop and start and
stop and you take something ten percent
through or 50 percent through or
sometimes even like 80% through but
unless you're willing to take it to a
hundred you're not gonna get the results
you're not going to get the fruit of
your labor because you're just planting
a whole bunch of
constantly but you're never taking care
of that seed you never watering it right
if you want to grow a plant you got to
plant the seed you got to care for the
soil you got to add nutrients you got to
water it daily it's got to have enough
sunshine you got to look after that seed
where most entrepreneurs they don't
they're starting soft by starting to
stop answering stopping and you never
actually get to where you want to go
people talk about diversification you
need to diversify you see diversify and
well that's really great as an
investment strategy if you don't know
what you're investing into it's good to
have a big portfolio of different things
so that if one thing doesn't do well
something else is doing well but it
really sucks his business advice because
if you're trying to do 10 different
things at once they're all gonna be
mediocre they're all going to be below
average because you're going up against
people who are doing that full-time and
have their focus on it and so it's much
better as an entrepreneur to one pick
the things that you want to focus on
right and then to actually focus on it
do that work Andrew Carnegie was once
the richest person in the world and he
had a great quote saying how he likes to
put all of his eggs in one basket and
then you watch that basket carefully
right it's only a major risk if you're
not watching the basket if you if you
take your eye off the ball you start
looking elsewhere and then something
happens to your industry right and so
being the expert being the best at what
you do will always yield more results
more value more money to you than being
okay at 20 different things be the best
at one thing focus and I know that's
tough because there's so many different
opportunities there's so many different
ideas that we come across as an example
when I got the chance to work with Lilly
and I took her under my wing and now
she's working for me as we start to
build up her business as being a public
speaker Lilly takes up my Wednesdays and
Wednesday was supposed to be right my
third book day and the third book is
something I'm really passionate about
really excited about it's gonna be how
to change your environment how to create
an environment for success from your
morning routine so your habits to your
rituals to your friends to the physical
environment I'm really passionate about
writing that book and I need to do a lot
of research to be able to complete it
but I can't do Lilly and the book at the
same time I had that one day open per
week because the other days are full at
least for now
and I had to decide book or lily and I
picked Lily and so the book is on the
back burner I haven't touched that in
months and I could try to do both but
they would both be mediocre and I wanted
to see Lily have massive success and
maybe when I could build her up to the
point where she's more free to do her
own thing and doesn't need as much of my
time I can go back and do the book I had
a guy write to me talking about my
facebook strategy and said hey if you do
Facebook better if you change the
pictures to look like this and if you do
more live streams and give me all sorts
of suggestions and and they're great
suggestions this is the challenge like
these are great ideas but I can't focus
on doing that and doing what I'm
currently doing at the same time and so
you have to prioritize focusing means
saying no you're gonna have tons of
opportunities come to you tons of ideas
that flow through your head that can all
be fantastic ideas but you cannot do all
of them right now so you need to
prioritize pick the right things to work
on and then put your blinders on focus
and just go out and execute you need to
be in execution mode you got to get that
thing done and it's great to dream and
it's great to have the big vision and
the big picture and lots of
opportunities but until you start acting
so you start doing none of the stuff is
gonna help so I highly encourage you to
start focusing so the question in
eternity is I'm curious what is the one
most important thing in your business
that you need to focus on they need to
dedicate significant amount of time
resources energy to to see this thing
through what is that one most important
thing for you to focus on in your
business share in the comments below
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to Joshua
Hudson Josh oh thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word I really really appreciate the
support and I hope you're enjoying the
read thank you guys again for watching I
hope you have an amazing day I believe
in you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
Spray so give me go
other than hard work what advice would
you give to better yourself both in life
and in your career field focus focus is
super underrated like if you commit all
that you are and all of your energy to
one thing you'll okay this like this
diagram this is I took this from a book
called I don't know what it's called but
it goes like this alright you can do 10
things to like the first degree like
this right here and that's how well
you'll do all 10 things or you can do
one thing to the 10th degree right there
and look how much better you do that so
when it comes to focus to put all of
your energy into one thing is to do that
one thing really well to the best of
your abilities to take it all the way
and to scatter yourself means you're
never actually accomplishing anything
you're just sort of chipping away at a
bunch of nothingness and this is true
for work this is true for like dating
versus committing yourself to one person
friendship everything like really
focusing and investing yourself into
something you're passionate about will
always yield better results then
scattering yourself around then
spreading yourself thin Warren Buffett
and Bill Gates simultaneously said one
word focus that's it
focus and in in in the many years that I
was 100% focused and I created a lot of
a lot of wealth for myself I only
thought about one thing and that was it
and I'm not I'm not saying that it's
easy because if it were easy there'd be
like a qlae shop on every corner like
Starbucks my market is seven hundred
thousand people out of seven billion if
you want to be me seven hundred thousand
out of seven billion I don't know what
fraction that is but it's not a very big
one that's it there's seven hundred
thousand people on the planet that can
commit to the focus the laser beam focus
of the gates Trump's Ellison's etc
if you if you want to if you want to
create generational wealth generational
wealth is wealth that you make in 20 to
25 years because depending on who where
you google it a generation age of 20 or
25 years we we do that and I've taught
and I did it myself how to do it in four
to seven years and the in virtually
throwing everything that you've learned
or read out the window but it's focused
and not that many people can stay
focused
in fact that's an understatement that
gross understand
hardly anybody can stay focused we
always had this a goal in sports and I
give the credit to my coaches for like
instilling that in me it's like always
creating this goal this part of time to
achieve something and during that time
nothing else mattered it didn't matter
what was happening in school for me it
didn't happen was you know relationships
didn't matter it was just like achieving
that goal yeah and maybe comes back to
like childhood or something where I just
wanted to be a great athlete but when I
get in that mind frame I guess I don't
know I just want to achieve the goal
more than anything else and that's
that's what I love to do